- Welcome back, y'all.
We are here with the cast
of "God's Favorite Idiot" on Netflix,
Melissa McCarthy, Ben
Falcone, Leslie Bibb,
and Kevin Dunn.
(audience applauds)
So this is a group of
passionate and creative people.
So we thought it would
be a good time to talk
about the things we love most in life.
Some of which might be a
little weirder than others.
That's right.
It's time to come clean
about our obsessions.
(jazz music)
(audience applauds)
All right.
Yep. It's time once again
to own our obsessions.
I've been so embarrassed
by this game on this show.
I don't get embarrassed,
but I feel like I should be.
My Dorito thing didn't go over well.
- Well, you do like Cheeto fluff
or something you like.
- Oh my God.
Okay. Here's the thing.
- Is it the dust?
- I don't like Doritos the chips.
- [Leslie] Oh yeah.
- Sorry. But I love
licking the cheese off.
(audience laughs)
And my tongue will feel
like, you know, like a cat's.
- Sandpaper!
- I really, it's one of my weird things
and I got shamed for it on this show.
- That's wonderful.
- It's weird.
But I don't like the chip.
I don't like how the chip
tastes or like either,
but I love the cheese.
I don't know.
- I have such a visual of you like.
(audience laughs)
- I literally have a separate bag.